this year at comic-con some of the
costumes have been the most elaborate
I've seen and I've come here maybe five
years in a row I mean guys who look
actually like iron man with the mask off
biker Scouts from Star Wars and I every
time I see somebody like that of course
I get the little nerd Terminator head-up
display where I start to be like Oh
biker scout Return of the Jedi uses this
kind of gun i had that action figure and
i do that for all of them makes it
really like ADHD to walk around the
convention floor but that also got me
thinking that those costumes engage me
and engage everybody else around in a
kind of weird porous like performance
space you know people who come to the
con and put on a costume are creating
their own kind of movie around them
their embodying the character who they
portray actually saw a guy dressed as a
green power ranger walk up to a mural
being painted only of red power rangers
and he was really upset that it was all
red instead of green like I was like
dude you know you're not really the
green power ranger right but of course
he did but then he didn't but what's
more important about those costumes is
that they engage the people around the
audience if you will in this kind of
virtual performance as either willing or
may be unwilling participants in the
performance itself they're not just
audience right there they're also
performers if I see people dressed as
Boba Fett I actually get to feel like
pretend I feel a little bit scared of
like a mandalorian bounty hunter walking
around San Diego even though I know that
it's not real there's no proscenium arch
performers will talk about performing in
the proscenium the arch over a stage but
that kind of thing doesn't exist here in
San Diego right everybody's on the
proscenium together and it's not just in
the convention floor the convention
metastasizes it spreads out around the
gas lamp district everything gets
redressed like the whole city is a set
and of course cities are always sets the
best cities are proscenium for the
people who walk around and live in them
I know that they have other more
important functions but they're also
places for all of us to perform for each
other to be each other's audience all
the time when I was in college I came
home to visit for the summer maybe and
my dad and I went out in LA and went to
a bookstore got a milkshake whatever and
we walk
out on to kind of a balcony looking at
the city and a couple of guys on
unicycles road by in front of us and it
just cracked us up we reminded us that
the city would deliver these kinds of
interesting things to look at and we
sort of laughed about that and then we
both turn back out to where we'd seen
the unicycles and this is back when
neither my dad was frequently grain or I
and we both looked a lot alike and at
the same moment we both took out our
clip on sunglasses and snapped him onto
our glasses and looked out over the city
and I realized when we did that that we
were part of the show to that we looked
just as funny or ridiculous or
interesting or whatever it is that we
expect the city to give us at anybody
else who was walking by that's one of
the reasons I like comic-con is that all
of us here are part of the same
performance